[Musik]
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video
er halte ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt
gut erstmal muss ich mich ganz kräftig
dafür entschuldigen dass das gestern um
19 uhr kein video gab das lag einfach
daran weil ich den ganzen tag rückreise
hatte und ich hatte kein video mehr
wir hatten einfach kein video mehr mainz
zu wenig vor gerät aber das ist
natürlich gar kein problem obwohl
gestern war es schon ein problem heute
nicht mehr weil heute kommt wieder 1
jeden tag um 19 uhr gibt es ja bei mir
ein youtube video und ich freue mich
sehr heute etwas zu testen was ihr auch
vom titel wahrscheinlich schon gelesen
habt und zwar sitze ich ja oft dann
abends da und macht so video plan für
die nächsten wochen monate und schreibt
immer bei den rein und ich habe mir
gedacht was ist wohl der günstigste
airport fake den mann so kaufen kann
also das ganze hab ich mir schon vor
über einem monat gedacht weil das dauert
ja auch mal lang das ist da ist deswegen
ist ich weiß es kam schon sehr viele
airport videos aber der letzte teil kann
man auch sehr gut an
deswegen machen wir einfach mal weiter
und ich habe tatsächlich airport text
gefunden weil nun für drei euro 3 euro
inklusive versand also wir haben nicht
noch versand fünf euro was drauf kommen
wir haben drei euro das produkt also das
produkt an sich kostet eigentlich nicht
mal ein euro in der herstellung weiß wie
ich mein das war schon verdammt günstig
ich kann es euch mal kurz zeigen damit
wir das auch genau dieses produkt habe
ich mir gekauft gut vom bild her sieht
es erst mal nicht so leicht aus aber ihr
könnt sie direkt lesen drei euro und da
ist wirklich kostenloser versand und
bald kann man ja hier auch sehen zehn
bis 27 tage versandzeit genau ich hab
sie mir auch so gern weiß geholte gibt
es anscheinend auch noch einen schwarz 3
euro also ich frag mich jetzt heute sind
diese dinge besser als die von tedi
kaufland das hatten wir noch action weil
bei denen war es ja immer so die waren
nicht so dass wir waren nicht zufrieden
und wenn diese jetzt besser sind für
drei euro das ja schon gut so weil die
anderen beiträge zum beispiel am 5 10
euro kosten
kaufland fast 30 euro action 10 euro und
sie haben wir einen park in drei euro na
gut ich will jetzt auch gar nicht so
viel rum la wir haben wir die elf tws
und ich würde sagen ich starte einfach
mal wobei ganz kurz was ich noch sagen
wollte ich habe gedacht wenn er potts
oder airport fakes halte 12 tws heißen
sind es immer genau die gleichen egal wo
man die bestellt also die haben jetzt
die elf tws und wenn du jetzt bei uschi
ftw es bestellen würdest würdest du das
gleiche modell bekommen da bin ich mir
mittlerweile sehr unsicher und glaube
das ist ja auch noch mal verschiedene
variationen gibt von ganz vielen
verschiedenen herstellern
und wenn man sich jetzt denkt ich
bestelle mir jetzt mal 20 11 tws kirche
waren auch wahrscheinlich zehn
verschiedene nochmal rein gut genug
genauer steilen natürlich schon
reingeguckt damit man weiß um was es
sich handelt und hier haben wir das
produkt kann man nicht darauf klar das
ist ja verdammt wenig oder schon wenig
dafür sieht schon mal nicht schlecht aus
natürlich haben wir hier eine etwas
andere verpackung die kommt nicht ganz
an die anderen verpackungen rankommen es
ist die erste verpackung die so aussieht
kein moment wie armani erbguts verraten
der ersten generation bisher länglich
angezogen um gut 1 kompatibel
ich bin gespannt okay die wiegen wie gar
nichts das ist ja leicht sagt gut das
habe ich mir schon gedacht wir haben ein
ganz normales us bc ladekabel
wir hatten ja auch schon sehr viele
airport fakes daten wir ein ladekabel
für apple
hier haben wir jetzt meinen 367 us
budget gut er ist auch nicht bei doch
keine beschreibung aber wahrscheinlich
nur chinesisch wie hier das ist mir auch
schon gedacht gut dafür man nichts mit
anfangen und hier am werk die airports
ich will mal ganz kurz noch meine
airports so also dass texte haben wir
uns ja darüber lustig dass hat ihr auch
so geklagt irrt diese soundcheck dinge
größter mühe eintritt 10 euro für das
und hier platz aus naja und mir fällt
auch direkt auf die ohrmuschel ist
riesig manchmal können nicht gekommen
einer kaum noch raus jetzt hier bin ich
blöd
die geräte nicht raus vergleichen wir
mal kurz mit denen hier weil das hier
waren
ich dachte wir euch ja meinst du 1
dasselbe modell aber haben wir nicht
nicht dass ich jetzt können wir eben was
durcheinander bringe summe an sieht man
einen kleinen unterschied
ein ganz ganz klein aber es sieht schon
verdammt ähnlich aus und jetzt bricht
das mal um und hier hinten sieht man es
auch das ist hier noch ein bisschen
größer als bei es ist hier bei dem td
airports noch ein bisschen größer alles
als bei den 11
bloß nicht verwechseln jetzt hier über
die man schnell wieder ins rhein guten
was mir aufgefallen dass bevor jetzt
sollten wir sagen irgendwie hast du
nicht schon längst verlor ist ja
eigentlich schon
ich habe bei noch 123 airports die ich
noch nicht verlost hat bei diesem thema
dingen jetzt zum beispiel ich weiß nicht
mehr da war irgendetwas mit dem versand
oder so oder der gewinner hatte sich
nicht gemeldet irgendwie so ich kann
nicht versprechen alles wo ich sage das
wird verlost verlor sich auch allerdings
war ich jetzt halt eineinhalb wochen gar
nicht hier
von daher hat sich das ein bisschen
verzögert aber ich setze mich jetzt die
woche da hin dass wir das auf jeden fall
noch hinkriegen könnte dann auch sehr
genau auf instagram verfolgen waren
meine story oder so wenn ich dann die
gewinner ermittelt ok dann würde ich
sagen wir sind eigentlich auch schon
beim punkt soll ich dir noch ganz kurz
mit den original
ich muss ich eigentlich gar nicht man
sieht ganz klar unterschiede extrem fed
extrem dünn
ja gut so viel dazu ich habe mich auch
gerade mal der halt zurück erinnert wie
viel ich dann damals für meine erste
airport sex bezahlt habt das war glaube
ich mich und ihrem neuen euro gekostet
oder sieben euro
also hier haben wir wirklich noch mal
deutlich weniger höchst interessant und
da würde ich sagen kann natürlich die
maschinell unserem iphone hier steht
schon direkt 11 ich kenne ich
mittlerweile schon ausweist ich weiß bei
jedem produkt direkt wie ich das koppel
ist gar kein problem für mich früher hat
das manchmal nach halbe stunde gedauert
bis wir die dinger gekoppelt haben und
japan die die sich die auf folgen hier
jetzt ganz einfach ihr drückt er ist auf
diesen knopf vom rechten dann blinkt das
leicht dann drückt er auf diesem hier
vom linken dann fahren die sich und dann
habt ihr praktisch ein pärchen was dann
hier bei dem smartphone angezeigt wird
hat sich selbst technisch korrekt
angehört so etwas funktioniert kommen
wir zum leben soundcheck meiner
lieblings tätigkeit eigentlich ich bin
gespannt weil wir schon eben angemerkt
wenn die jetzt besser sind als die
tübinger die kaufland dinger die action
dinger wobei bei den action länger davon
so schlechter kann es eigentlich nicht
sein das war ja ein kompletter reinfall
checkt das video auf jeden fall noch
abzocke sondern geil neue künstler
entdeckt hast du auch das video gesehen
thiago silva hat gesehen der ganzen mehr
angezeigt das war richtig halte sondern
haben wir jetzt mal an
dollar
[Musik]
ich bin schockiert ist also das ist dass
das ist jetzt also ein rückschlag für
mich ich habe wirklich gehofft dass das
gut ist das ist ja hier letztes mal die
action dinge die ich zufälligerweise
jetzt auch noch hier weil das video hat
erst letzte woche montag haben und ich
schon sonntag weggeflogen
aber damals ja schon ein kompletter
reinfall täter wendet das in die ohren
stecken willst es mal war
doch kaum einmal ja einmal haben ganz
kurz alter und ich mache genau in
schwung an den ich gerade hat okay ich
mache wieder von vorn okay
bist du bereit
willst du wissen wie drei euro klingt
drei euro klingt so diesen jungen machen
wir jetzt spaß und laut ging es dann los
mit dem bock mit den worten hey junge
junge alter vor allem ich weiß noch wie
wir beim wie wir bei den action angesagt
haben ja mir ist das ne scheiße aber das
ist noch deutlich schlimmer oder das
krause das hört sich ja an alters
internet für teile darin verbaut was da
so einen klang rauskommt trasse gut aber
dass man kurz noch nicht
und vielleicht ist das mikrofon ja gut
und du deine wenigstens etwas sein kann
man die zum telefonieren benutzen
auf höchster stufe waren dass li na ganz
klar
alter ist das okay ich wollte sich anja
hier ja auch der sprache
ja man versteht die wörter nicht ganz
also ich glaube wenn du unter leuten das
wird man nicht gar nicht verstehen ach
ja und ich mach mal kurz distanz
ich habe jetzt können wir hier von
abrutschen
roller an gemacht ich fand dagegen ich
jetzt eigentlich also kann sein dass sie
gerade amstrong lag dass es sich so
grausam anhört klar jetzt ist auch nicht
gut aber jetzt würde ich nicht unbedingt
sagen dass es schlechter ist als bei den
action er auf einer stufe
davor absolute katastrophe oftmals liegt
auch am song
das geht jetzt eigentlich schlag des
tages auch vorbei wir da ja schon die
vermutung hatten das in jedem dieser
dinger das gleiche bluetooth zeit
verbaut ist von daher geht auch hier das
ohne probleme bis dahin also über zehn
meter vom landrat sieht auf jeden fall
hat man fazit und zwar wie auch schon
bei den action dinger falls ihr euch für
fakes interessiert hofft euch auf keinen
fall diese für drei euro weil diese drei
euro könnt ihr dann ich sage immer so
schön auch direkt vor ihrer haustür in
die mülltonne schmeißen das ist wirklich
kompletter quatsch ist jetzt das einzige
was bei uns in den tests gut
abgeschnitten hat waren die 200 tws und
die 1000 ews und aber auch die von
kaufland die waren auch halbwegs gut
bezahlt werden aber auch schnell
zwischen 20 und 30 euro für die man ein
bisschen mehr geld in die hand als euch
hilfe dreier um sowas zu kämpfen oder
für sieben euro
was wir heute das war es mit dem
nächsten test schick mir weitere auf
insider ich fahre jetzt später noch zum
netto da gibt es nur heute ein neues
produkt neue ihr bugs für 20 euro glaube
ich die wollte ich auch mal kaufen wenn
ihr noch was habt demnächst wollte auch
noch zum mediamarkt und vielleicht mal
was etwas hochwertiges kaufen
ja ich würde sagen wir sehen uns morgen
19 wieder programm alex wie diese teile
ich nicht verlosen 1 x als kompletter
bullshit ist das braucht keiner aber ihr
könnt ihr sehr gerne trotzdem ins album
folgen jeden tag mainz nur ein video
aber die den kanal blog aktivieren wir
sehen uns morgen 3